the car
get out of the car
he just took off he's he's rammed this
time
it's a red Volvo he just went down a
Colorado driver is killed during a
traffic stop moments after being tased
and speeding off from the cops he's
running across I-70 right now he just
got hit send Medics now all this just
minutes after the driver expresses
concern for standing in the middle of
the road let's go the road right here I
think yep I got this Lane here the
Colorado State Patrol released body and
dash camera footage from the deadly
crash on June 1st shortly before two
o'clock that morning a trooper noticed a
wrong way driver in the city of golden
okay
um I'm trying to get back up to
Blackhawk but
body camera video shows the trooper
approaching the driver who begins
talking about nearby road construction
okay what's all messed up uh the Bros
are all under construction going on you
know okay how'd you get on this side of
the road oh well I actually just flipped
around right here I'm pretty sure you
saw me yeah yeah I'm just saying when
did you get on this I literally just put
down right here you flipped around yeah
like I thought I'd just come back this
way but apparently not you know what I
mean yeah definitely not the trooper
then asks for the driver's license
yeah okay you got your driver's license
on you um
actually I'm sorry I had a wrong way
driver
um it's gonna be the I-70 westbound exit
the C470 eastbound I'll get you a plate
here in a second
oh
how's it going uh someone's available
but I think we're okay right now
you got your driver's license yeah
um let's see
if you do my name
yeah because I don't have a license
actually you have an ID on you I don't
have an idea
what's that production nope just hang
tight
after this the driver notes they should
step out of the road likely for fear of
being hit by oncoming traffic let's get
on the road right here I think yep I got
this right in here stay just stay here
hold on don't get back in the car don't
hey don't get back in the car don't get
back in the car what up bro don't get
back in the car no you're not flipping
around step out of the car
you're not flipping around get out of
the car as the traffic stop continues
the driver continues to resist the
trooper ignoring his commands and
instead demanding a cigarette eventually
the trooper attempts to detain him hang
on man yeah
come over here
I want you to go right here okay
other people see what these cars are
going to say yeah have a seat on that
for me
have a seat on that for me can I get a
cigarette please you can have a
cigarette have a seat on that all right
okay you got anything in your pockets no
okay let me check don't dig in your
pockets for me don't dig in your pockets
man come on man stop
ahead put your hands in no I don't have
a cell phone put your hands on your back
cell phone I don't care put your hands
on your back I'm just detaining you
right now I'm detailing you right now
don't fight with me don't fight with me
please sir no no you're not listening
stop don't fight me I need a cigarette
don't fight don't bring this on dude
don't fight dude please don't stop dude
no stop stop
dude stop stop
dude I need a cigarette oh dude
no calm down dude no come on dude
we're past I'm not putting you in the
restaurant just to tell you right now
stop let me see it bad dude no
we're gonna give him a vaporizer bro
stop no stop no hope please stop all
right stop reaching pocket that's what I
want you to stop doing come on dude here
okay let's go ahead
okay don't reach in your pockets quit
stop what do you want me to do I want
you to stop I want to put you in
handcuffs I want to be in here bro I
don't care dude I'm not going to hang
over there I can't trust you right now
man but the driver heads back to his
vehicle getting out a cigarette come on
bro
stop
what are you doing in your car
stop you're gonna get tased dude stop
you're gonna get changed cigarette bro
you want to change the point get out of
the car
get out of the car
quit digging in your pockets dude when
the driver still does not listen to the
trooper's demands he's tased
stop you're gonna get tased oh dude stop
stop
the trooper warns that he will fire the
taser again but before that the driver
takes off get out of the car get out of
the car now you're gonna get tased again
stop get out of the car
get out of the car
ever one over six he's taken off on his
car
body camera footage from a backup
Trooper shows the same moment from a
different angle showing the drivers
speed off
get out of the car
[Applause]
he just took off he's he's rammed the
sign dash camera footage also captures
the Mayhem but she has two radio channel
I think they did the Bluetooth
immediately after the man drives off
Troopers begin to run after him
it's a red Volvo he just went down the
ramp
the driver headed down an embankment
onto Interstate 70. seconds later he's
hit he's running across I-70 right now
he just got hit send Medics now
70 eastbound at the 2-6-0
he just got hit he's down there
but
[Applause]
all right
Troopers can then be heard calling for
backup and the closure of the interstate
get on the road
[Applause]
to everyone six we need to shut down 70
eastbound
[Applause]
I was going to the Fatal
he's wrong away on 470 here okay stop
we're 10-4
it's gonna be a code Frank we just need
to get 70 eastbound shut down body
camera video picks up one Trooper saying
the driver got hit by a passing vehicle
yeah yeah
no he got hit by a car he got hit by a
car so up there he's fighting me
uh he tries taking off suspect is the UA
meanwhile the backup Trooper checks out
a nearby vehicle that pulls over after
the crash are they okay I'm gonna go
check on them right now
I'm not even sure which one hit him
huh you guys okay
you guys didn't hit him right no he was
the people left there in the front okay
okay
hang around
are you okay yeah
okay
officials say the driver was pronounced
dead on the scene right now his name
isn't being released publicly and the
Crash is still under investigation
reporting for long crime Network I'm
Sierra Gillespie